i tell people two to five three to eight
percent of your
liquid net worth diversified put into
crypto that's my i don't understand why
everyone advertises this diversification
crap diversification is garbage like
tell me how many tell me i'm wrong teach
me something go ahead warren buffett
himself says it's stupid and he only has
to do it because he has so much money he
hasn't what do you mean by
diversification yeah
you think i should put 100 of the crypto
yep yes i do
really yes i do so you shouldn't have
hear me out yeah anything in the stock
market forget about 401ks roth iras
forget about that kind of stuff like
that
um reits real estate anything with that
trash all trash all trash so the only
thing you're saying 100 you said cash
and crypto cash and crypto yeah yeah
it's worked out real good for me i'm
sure it has so like but you also got
into bitcoin when 2011 when it was
[ __ ] 10 cents
you're you're a godfather in that
theorem was just 88 bucks like a year
and a half ago now it's uh you know two
thousand bucks so
you know
these opportunities keep availing
themselves pulsechain.com is gonna come
out you know hopefully soon hex.com is
on a nine percent dip now like
we have these things where you're lucky
enough that they dip that you can get an
entry
there's some things that never dip like
like try and catch a dip on like uh
amazon i guess you can but yeah but if
you look at the crazy if you look at the
chart historically it is like up and to
the right forever and it's like
so
why would you okay here's the theory
somewhat someone somewhere said that you
should diversify and then everyone
thought yeah that sounds good but then
they never actually put any thought into
it like if i were to
i could beat you up about this i wanted
to i want
why do you think diversification is good
well asset allocation you're saying i
mean
i'm not going to keep okay hear me out
i'm not going to keep all my money bust
your balls on this fine i want to learn
so it's all good we're having fun
i don't want to keep all my money in
cash i'd probably say ten percent of my
trash it just goes to zero cool i get
that yeah but the only super super
wealthy people can dare say cash is
trash
75 percent of americans live in paycheck
to paycheck brother go tell the average
american that cash is trash you're
getting slapped in the face verbally not
physically okay so you can't say that
ray dalio said that at the world
economic forum in [ __ ] davos
pre-covered and then it was like
everyone's like yeah thanks ray dalio
your
billionaire hedge fund guy the rest of
the world needs cash they respect what
do you mean they don't need cash you
when you have the ability to instantly
convert a real asset into cash on a
just-in-time basis you do not need to
expose yourself to the only goes to zero
fiat currency horror and the rest of the
world has it far worse
the dollar is at all time low value
but other currencies are at 40-year low
value versus the dollar so those guys
got screwed even harder yeah the
dollar's pretty strong right now yeah
the euro lost a third of its value over
the last 14 years versus the dollar and
the dollar lost a massive amount it's
value versus the stuff that you want
like versus big macs they keep getting
more expensive
so
yeah i go to the uh if you go to the
dollar store everything's two bucks now
right the dollar menu at mcdonald's
everything's like dollar 49. it's like
what just happened here guys 100 bro 100
it's because it's not because the stuff
went up in price it's because the dollar
is worth nothing now and it will
continue to do that it will continue to
devalue that dollar until it's worth
nothing
so if you can sit in any type of real
asset that they just don't print for fun
all the time like the dollar and then
convert as needed then you don't get
wrecked holding the dollar like if you
if you had 100 000 of savings 10 years
ago well guess what the interest rate
you earned didn't meet inflation you
lost money saving okay let's play a game
ready because i want to i want to gotta
bust your balls yeah why diversification
starts i want to i want to stay here so
if you uh this is about that
diversification let's say someone has a
hundred grand in cash yeah let's just
use an easy number some people be like
oh my god i wish i had a hundred grand
some people were like hundred grand i
mean i'm a [ __ ] millionaire he's
probably losing four percent of you okay
in in
most people would say all right you take
a good portion of that make sure that's
in your retirement account retirement
fund i assume you're not working with
401ks these days bro or roth iras peter
thiel just turned a 401k into like five
billion dollars somehow but that's a you
know that's a whole other story it's
very easy he just put his shares of his
startups in the thing that's it it's a
taxi you can take advantage tax-free the
whole thing but a lot of people will say
have some in the stock market you know
have some stuff yeah really why though
okay why because crypto didn't exist at
that point bro tell me yes when did the
crypto become mainstream it was stupid
when did crypto become mainstream like
to the point where you could say it's
not mainstream
that's why do you still have stream now
no it's still not mainstream that's why
there's still opportunity meaning like
if i put a gun
with your crypto wallet right now you'd
be dead because you don't have that like
you don't have a crypto wallet on your
phone you don't have a thousand dollars
to send me you probably don't know how
to use it you don't remember your
password it's not mainstream at all it's
not mainstream at all
so you're saying the actual concept of
having a crypto wall everyone yeah
nobody what i mean what i mean is
everyone knows what bitcoin is right no
that's mainstream i don't i don't think
they do
everyone knows what bitcoin
no
they don't sh
to somewhere in the world that they
don't want to go
we could go mobile and just interview
people on the street on this one and say
and say have you heard of bitcoin but
what does that mean it doesn't matter if
they've heard of it but that's what
mainstream is yeah pop culture they know
about it i'm not saying they have a
crypto wallet
and then they can
i'm not saying i think i think cell
phones were mainstream when people owned
them not when they heard of them i think
crypto's mainstream when you have a
wallet not when you heard of it i don't
think a heard of it is a good mess like
heard of it is not useful like people
people have heard like
people heard of tiger king doesn't mean
he's a mainstream anyway so look back to
the diversity back to birth
diversification is [ __ ] it's really
stupid
here's a good performing asset here's an
amazing performing asset and here's a
trash performing asset let me get a
little bit of each one let me let me
sprinkle some dookie on my spaghettios
because like it's different and
different's better for a reason i can't
answer like no difference not better
you've got something that's the best
performing asset class of all time which
is cryptocurrency that removes
counterparty risk which makes things
more efficient which
solves problems like the one you saw in
canada where you buy a sandwich for
someone at a political event and now
they seize your bank account yeah that
happened i remember canada seized
people's bank accounts for buying
sandwiches for other people horrible
performing a peaceful horrible situation
crypto solves that like there's so many
things wrong with the world right now
and one of the only good things out
there that's solving some of those
things is cryptocurrency and so not only
do you get to be rich and and actually
own your own money and actually hold
your own keys and not have to beg the
credit card company to turn your card
back on to beg your credit card company
or your bank to send the money where you
want to send it with worse hours worse
fees the lowest interest rates have ever
existed it's all the least number of
branches the least number of atms an
actual war on cash globally
everything sucks except crypto it's
going good
so
why would i dilute my crypto gains when
i could buy the dip with a bunch of this
other garbage that takes 14 years to 2x
and i'm still paying capital gains tax
i'm still only paying 20 cap gains tax
if you hold it a year
why like why would i bother with all
that stuff that sucks now i can answer
that question for you okay i can tell
you
the reason why people thought that uh
diversification made sense
if you have a bunch of things that are
volatile
and you spread that volatility out
it reduces the chance that if you have
to sell for some reason you're selling
like a local bottom in that thing and so
if you spread your volatility out a
bunch across across a bunch of stuff
then
you can end up with slightly better
returns or you could just buy the thing
that went up a million percent
instead of this limp dick trash wait 14
years to get a 2x and by the way that's
still better than real estate like the
stock market's still better than real
estate
and historically so like
if you only have cash
please buy an index fund of the s p 500
if you have real estate uh stuff
probably you're going to do better in
stocks they traditionally do better but
real estate traditionally does better
than stuff no the other way stocks
better than real estate correct so like
correct
and then why not just do the thing that
over performs like you could have
invested 10 times less money and made 10
times more money in crypto and then and
then like
you have less risk like you only put up
10 you only put up one tenth of the
money that you would have otherwise had
to put up so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]